Women entrepreneurs [Owned] ten Point Six Million Businesses in The United States They Employ 19 Point 1
Million Workers That's One in Seven Employees Their businesses account for
2.5 Trillion Dollars in Sales With that in Mind here are the Top 50 Rules for Success for Women Entrepreneurs
Well I'm A very Curious Person and and That Curiosity Really Is i think at the basis for
All the kinds of Things that I like to try and Experiment With and and
Attempt and and We have a good Time doing it it's not it's not so much being driven as much as being
Interested in A lot of Different Things
the Way Through the Challenge
Is to get Still and ask Yourself what is the next right Move
Not Think About
Oh I got all [of] This of it what is the next right Move and then from that Space
Make the next right Move and the next right Move and not to be Overwhelmed by it because you know your life [is] bigger than
That One, Moment you know
You're Not defined by what somebody Says is a Failure for you because Failure Is [Just] There to point you in A Different Direction
Failure gave Me an Inner Security that I had Never Attained by Passing Examinations
Failure Taught me Things About Myself that I could Have learned no other way I?
Discovered That I had a strong will and more Discipline Than I had Suspected I
Also Found out that I had friends Whose Value was truly above the Price of Rubies
The Knowledge [That] you Have emerged Wiser and Stronger from Setbacks Means that you are ever after
Secure in Your Ability to Survive
You will Never Truly know Yourself or the Strength of your relationships until both Have Been Tested by Adversity
Such Knowledge is a true gift
For all that it is Painfully one and
It has Been Worth more Than Any Qualification I ever earned [I]
Played A lot of Sports When I was Younger and I settled on Soccer because the 99 Would Seem Really Motivated me?
my dad Would go out on the Soccer Field with me Every Day and it pushed Myself in A good Way and
Motivated Me [to] be the Best I can, be
Soccer was Just my thing and I wanted to Make it to the Us women's National Team
My Favorite Goal
Was gainst Italy I Scored in Probably The 93rd Minute and I think that's One of the Best Parts of my game Is my finishing
Everyone has Their Talent but it's what you do With that talent to [Make] it great
Everything [that] I've Done I've Worked so hard
From until my toes Are Bleeding and no Complaints so it takes so much Hard Work and I think
The more You have to Work for something the more you cherish it and
Every Time I think About doing something Silly Or something that's Going to be Detrimental to my Career that I built I think About all
That Time I've Sacrificed in My Childhood and my Family and all the people that Worked so hard and I could Never
Disrespect
All that I worked for I could Never Disrespect my fans I can Never disrespect the
Opportunity That I've Been Given [When] you develop your Business Plan
Don't be Afraid to write Everything Down everything that Comes Into your mind
Because Ultimately if You have A good Business Plan
Well-Thought-out
Well-Designed Carried out For A year Or two, or three you Can start to follow that Plan in an Orderly Fashion
Does it always Work it doesn't always Work it all doesn't always turn out the way you think it's going to turn out
You might the Stumble or trip or fall in A Gully but if You have the plan you can get Up and
Continue on your Path Nothing About my life is lucky
Nothing
A lot of Grace A lot of blessings [a] lot of
Divine Order
But I don't believe in Luck
For Me luck is Preparation Meeting the moment of Opportunity?
There is no luck
Without You being Prepared to Handle that moment of Opportunity and so what I would Say for [Myself] Is is that?
Because of my Hand in A hand and A Force Greater than my own
I have Been Prepared in Ways that I didn't even Know
I was being Prepared for and the truth Is for Me and for every
Person Every
Single Thing That has ever Happened in your life
Is preparing you for the moment that is to come I was on the Train from Manchester to London
And it Came Just Came Had something like That ever Happen to you before yes
Truthfully I mean other Ideas Have Just come to me Because I think if you're a writer and
That's what you Spend A Huge amount of Time doing you do ideas do come to you but Nothing had ever Come
so with such a [high] [Hadith] I thought god loved to write that and
When I got off The train I went straight [home] When I started writing I'm not Worried about
My Future about what i'm going to do in ten Years after Soccer it's about right now you know How I can
Contribute To the team's Success how
I can Make [sure] that you know I'm Physically Mentally Ready for each Game so it's it's Really Just
Taking it [day] by day and Knowing that
You know the Future is so Uncertain you just need to be happy where you are right Now and Just
Have a positive Outlook on it i'm Competitive
Really With Myself Right
Honestly Like Every Time I start an Album I
Go and Watch all of my performances?
and I try to Figure out
Okay, what is it that I could have Done Better or what Worked and?
Really My References I go back to [Myself] and Trying to better Myself so I'm Really Tough on?
Me more so than than Anyone Else I'm not A competitive Person That Walks in
Thinking About other People and How [I] can compete [With] Them more Especially not my Husband I
Really Encourage Them if They have a great, Idea to run with it
find ways to
To Finance find Ways to build find ways to
Market you don't have to hold Yourself Hostage to who you used to be or Anything you ever used to do
Cuz who has lived and Hasn't Made Mistakes when I think about my 20s and what A foolish girl I was and
How I would give over my power to men who?
Really Didn't mean Me
Well but Now i hold no grudges against them either because I realized i'm The one Who gave over the Power
Because I Didn't know Any Better and now that I know Better [I] know
I don't have to do that again it's one of the most Powerful Lessons Any of Us can ever know
It is one of the Amazing and Wonderful Things About Literature as about Film and Music Is it's utterly Subjective
so
Somebody's Point of it you know that's The Point of Course you
Won't you Move in That World if You Expect us to stand under a shower of Perpetual Praise There's something Wrong With Exactly that you?
Know you will you will get criticism I knew That Going in and the Funny Thing, Is I'm not Particularly
[I] was never A very Confident Person in Their Areas in my life in Which I'm [very] Thin-skinned
But not in This Area in This Area [I] i think it's right and Proper I should be Criticized [and] that's that's
Angela so in The Morning I get a good night's Sleep and Then in the
[I] try and get out here on Alki and Just Kind of Walk [Around]
It's just a really beautiful place to kind of start your Morning and Have a positive Mentality going Into your day
Yoga Definitely Fits Into my life in Terms of Preparation it's great Just to have that sense of Feeling at ease With Yourself
Stretching is A Huge Part of Soccer and Making sure That
you Know
You're Pretty Flexible and I just love the Feeling of Kind of being alone a little bit and being able to
Take my mind off The Soccer but at. The same Time the Reason I go to yoga is to Help me Succeed in Soccer [I]
Always was A creative Child and I my Parents Encouraged it and I always
Was doing something creative was whether it was writing Songs or Poems or?
Making Clothes Or dancing Putting on Shows
Whatever it was something Creative I [think] that that's so Wonderful for Kids I think it Just
It gives you so much
Confidence and You Just Feel, so what's so good about Yourself and you feel like you can
Accomplish Anything [and]
Creativity Can't be Judged so
You Just it Just is great for self-Esteem for Kids
Once You Develop A large Customer Base and We reach about a hundred Million
People Every Month With all our Various Businesses our Books our Magazines or Television?
[and] Once You develop that kind of Close Rapport they Have Already A
Feeling that I'm Providing them with things [that] you [Didn't] Watch so it's very Important to
Engender Trust
With your Customer if You Disappoint Them i mean if you Make something that falls Apart forget it you
Don't get That Customer Back again and all I want to do is Grow my Customer [Base]
I want to be Where that Customer Needs and Once I say to the my girls all of the Time
That your Real Work
Is to Figure out
Where your power base Is and
To Work on the Alignment of [your]?
Personality your gifts that you have to give With the real Reason why
You're Here That's that's the Number One Thing [you] have to do is to Work on Yourself and to fill
your Self Up and Keep your Cup full Keep
Yourself Full Now I used to be Afraid of that I used to be Afraid
Particularly from People who Say, oh she said She Still fell out of them
Or something and Now I embrace it [I]
Considered A Compliment [that] I am Full of
Myself
Because you only when, you're Full I'm Full I'm Overflowing my Cup runneth, over?
I have so much I have so much to Offer and so much to Give and I am not Afraid of
Honoring Myself You Know it's Miraculous when you think About it your onsen [Hair] Mm-Hmm
This is Really the room
What i finished [Philosopher's] [Stone] in Here?
This is Really Where I turned my life Around Completely and We Made my life Change so much in This Flat
I
Feel I really Became Myself Here in That everything stripped away, I made Such A mess of things but that, was all that was Freeing
So i thought well I want to write
So I wrote the Book and what was the worst That Can Happen it Gets [tuned] Down Baby publishing written big Deal
So you know it's really back to the whole Time Here
My Bedrooms Are Locked Where my bedroom me Bedroom it's A lot Tidier Now God
[God] that's Mad [I] suppose a tick When I have to?
Hold it Harry Potter Books
Now That's Really Freaky
And for Years Now I felt that if it all Disappeared and some Days I do Feel like it is it real
Then This is Where I would come back to you know this Would be my Baseline, I'd be Back in Leith
and Obviously if I'D known that
Tenure well was it A year 10 Years Old?
I'D come Back here with A film Crew and There Would be my published Books in Someone Else's
Bookcase in This Room I mean it's Really incredible to me
You Really Did i mean
yes
Because it's Such A, well-Worn part of my story now it's a big Yawn to hear
How I wrote it as Though it
Was all some Sort of Publicity stunt I did For A year but it was my life and it was very Hard
And I'd know There was gonna be This
[Fairy] Tale Resolution I
Might Advise Coming Back hits Just Below ghosts I
Didn't Expect When I sprained my ankle Back in October Talked?
Over that it Would come to this and that was the hardest part [for] me it
Was kind of doubting Myself like, well you know why Didn't I?
Why Didn't i take it Easier why, Didn't I kind of Pull Myself out of Training or out of the game but
You Can't Look back you kind of Just need to look Forward it was it was Definitely Hard but I feel like
Now that I'm Actually Seeing Improvement
We just Gotta am [Rhein] It Kind of helps me a little bit Mentally to be [able] to
Do Bike a little bit to be able to swim I wasn't able to do Anything on Crutches so?
Now Knowing [That] There's Improvement I'm able to do some Stuff I feel A lot more I guess Happy
Progression As an Artist Is the most Important Thing for me That
Is what Success Is for me I feel like if I stay in One Spot I'm not doing my Job
[I'm] not Growing as a human being and
I'm
Wasting Time and I feel like i always want to do something
Different From what I did in the past I
Always want to challenge Myself I always want to have that Nervous Ball in my Stomach before I go on the Stage that's how I
Know I'm doing the right Job and it's something Still exciting for Me and I always want to challenge the Music Industry [I] feel like
It's kind of my Job [to] create the New of Tempos it's kind of my Job to set the tone and
To be the example so it's sometimes Risky but it's the only Reason I've Been able to
Last for As Long as I have in this Industry Because it's Really Short lived and
I feel like if People Can Predict your next move it's Just not Interesting and
I'll be Bored so i'm Bored if I'm Bored Everyone Else is Bored
Every [Business] has
And and I don't like to think of Things as Obstacles all the Time I'd like to think them as
Challenges to be Solved and Problems to be dealt with and I would Say to my team, [well] doesn't Matter, Cuz every
Season Somebody Else was Coming out
One Talk Shop to [talk] Shows Three Structures There have been over a hundred Talk Shows since We started but Every Time I
Would Feel like alright got to step up our Game got to step up our Game
The way you Step up your game is not [to]
Worry About the other Guy in Any Situation because you can't Control the other Guy you?
[Cannot] Control The other Guy You only Have Control, over Yourself so it's like running a race
The Energy that it Takes To Look back and See where the other Guys are Takes Energy away from you and if They're too close
It Scares you so that's what I would Say to my team all the Time
Don't waste your Time in the Race Looking back to see where the other Guy is or?
What the other Guy? Is doing it's not About the other Guy it's About
What Can you?
Do you just need to run that Race as hard as you Can you need to give it everything you've got [all] the Time
for Yourself I
Remember Once and it, was Like it was like
Well like i'm gonna Call it clash Clash of Clairvoyants now Obviously if I hadn't come True I would Just be Around and Crazy for?
Dad But I do Remember one [Day] writing Philosopher's Stone I was Walking away from the cafe Where I've Been Working
Philosopher's Stone Which Became Which Became Sorceress Knowing Exactly so that's the first Novel and I had this moment Where I Suddenly Thought
It was like Another Voice Speaking to me in The Voice said the difficult things gonna be to get published
If it's published it will be Huge
WoW and that is Exactly what it was so there was some
Hint that the voice had Said to you
Well the Thing is you've [Got] to believe haven't you yes You know I was I was not the, World's most secure Person?
I
Wasn't someone With an Enormous Amount in Fact I'd Say?
I was someone With not much Self Belief at all and [getting] This one Thing in my life I
Believed That was the one Thing in my life I felt I can tell a story
before [A] game the key to my Preparation Is
Consistency I really Think That Every Athlete is a little bit Superstitious and if an Athlete Tells you otherwise I think They're lying
So yes I do A couple things I Definitely
Put on my [red] Sock before my left Sock and i like to take a nap at the same Time and
Eat the Same Things and Then right before the game I like to do a lot of Mental
Visualization so I'll go in A locker and Just put on Headphones and Just Imagine Myself in the game I
Would Say to Continue to Work Hard [and] don't give up on your Goals [and] I know?
For me Like i [said] I grew up Watching my family
Struggle and I Grew Up with a family that was Successful but not Born
Successful and I believe With Hard Work and with A goal and and Love and Positivity Then Eventually!
We're Going to be fine When I started the Business the Martha Stewart Living Omnimedia
Our two words were Inspire and inform
so you create the beautiful Picture you create the Lifestyle that you think Everybody Would Aspire to
and then you have to tell the tale again so that's the teaching Part and May that Inspire that
Inspiration You have to know what you can't Fake it
so i learn every single day One of my Mottos [is] learn something new Every Day and
I do so it's it's all about Informing [Yourself] so that you can be a good teacher my Grandmother
Was a Maid that's all she [ever] Knew
The Only Real Expectation She Held for me
Was [that] I Would One day become a Maid and in her Words have some good White Folks Meaning People who Would not?
Speak Negatively about me who Would, allow me to take food home who, Would be good to me Would treat me With some level of?
Dignity and Respect that was my Grandmother's dream for me
But I had Another dream for Myself
Another More Than A dream I had a belief
for Myself and I remember Watching her
Hang out Clothes on A line One Day and Say to me you have to Watch me Oppa Gayle Cuz
One day you'll have to do this for [Yourself] and
Knowing inside Myself that that was not going to be my life don't know How I knew it other
Than That Thing that We all have?
Intuition Or an Instinct that Said no this will not
Be my life but Because I sensed that and was Connected [to] that and [I] remember
Was A very Still moment
It was Quiet and I was Still and I was Watching her I could See her right Now With the Clothes Pins in her Mouth?
and
Putting Them on the line and Seeing the Breath
Because it was Cold the Moisture Coming from her Lips and
I knew that that Would not be my life I knew that I will not be hanging Clothes on A line in
A back Yard in Mississippi so [I] was either four or five Years Old and?
That
Belief that that Would not be my life, Is what I held [Onto] for the longest of Times I just no matter what
Believed That There was something
Bigger Greater More
for me
There's Always Trepidation I mean I [think] that People might [be] Surprised to know [that] I felt Trepidation Every Time I produced a potter Book
You know The weight of Expectation There was was?
I won't Say Crushing it was extraordinary and [Wonderful] to have that weight of Expectation but a Duty With Yourself yeah and with the
Expectations
Laterally of Millions of Fans all of whom were very Invested in The Story and Wanted to see what they wanted to see and
I knew where I was going and i i had to put on Mental blinkers A lot and Just Think I know Where i'm Going
I must not be Influenced by this
When People ask me How [i] balance nan [Tiger] stuff the things off the Fields?
you Know I think it
Is i've Been more Confident in the last couple of Years With the Decisions I Make [and] Opportunities that are given and
Decisions Whether to go Through with it [or] not you know
If it's Authentic to who I am and you know Whether it's a company I'm Representing or whether it's an Event I'm Going to whether
It's A
Photo Shoot That I've Been Asked to do I think it's you [know] it's just Weighing all of the things and Making sure That Nothing
Is Standing in the way of what I do Best and what I'm Here for Let's Play Soccer [I]
Think a star is Born a star
Absolutely I think I
Know me I was born to do what I do it's
Just Too natural There's Certain things that I know
No One Taught me no one Can teach you it's Just you are and
I
Feel like, We all are Stars We all Have that?
We just have to figure out what that Thing [Is] that we're Supposed to be Doing in Life and I know that
For me to know Exactly what I was born to do at such a young age Is why I've Been able to?
Do what I do as
Well
As i do it because I've Been
Doing it for a really Long Time and I'm doing the right Thing [I've] Ever Cried [in] Business Ever Retired for pride yes
No I refuse
How do you, well I think if I cry but I don't cry [at] this you don't kind Business
No I don't think Business is Worth Crying over I think you have to like and
Concentrate [on] Business you Can Build your Business you Can Help Others Build Businesses and and its Business
It's not about Emotion [it's] About Really Going for it you can be Passionate [that's]
That's Only Emotion I allow in my Business I always Understood [that] There Really was no Difference between Me in The Audience
At Times I might have Had Better Shoes but at. The core the core of
What Really Matters that, [We] are the same you know How I know that Because?
All of Us Are Seeking the Same Thing you're here at this Fabulous School and
We'll go out Into the World and each Pursue based upon what you believe your talents are
What your Skills Are Maybe your? Gifts Are what you're Seeking the Same Thing everybody wants [to] fulfill
The highest
Truest Expression of?
Yourself as A human being That's what you're Looking for the highest
Truest Expression
Of Yourself as a human being and Because I understand that I understand that if You're Working in a Bakery and
That's Where you want to be and
That May Be that that May be what you've Always wanted to do is to Bake
Pies for People Or Bake Cakes for People or to offer your
Gift
Then Then That's that's for you and There's no Difference between you and me except that's how that's your Platform that's your Show every day?
so my
Understanding of that has Allowed Me to you know they aren't Restricted to reach Everyone and and There's no way, that you
Wouldn't Because that's that's what I truly Feel?
Even A Time-Turner [I]
Would Tell my 21 year Old Self that personal happiness Lies in Knowing that life Is not A checklist of?
Acquisition Or achievement
your Qualifications your CV are not your life Though you will Meet Many People of my age and Older
Who Confuse the two
Life Is difficult and Complicated and Beyond Anyone's Total Control and
The Humility to know That will enable you to survive its Vicissitudes I
Think There's no secret to Success i mean I think I'll be Definitely
Hit The Nail, on the Head it's it's all about hard. Work it's all about going out There and and
Practicing More Than your opponent than your teammates it's it's about Mentally Preparing Every Single day it's about not Slacking off
Putting in That Time and Work and you
[Could] Tell from abby that she Is put in [That] Work and
That's I think the Reason that she [hooks] is so Successful but at the end of the day end of the day There is no
There is no
Secret to why, we are so Successful
Well trish [Just] oh I know who you are?
Work very Hard how Long did it Take you to be able trust Yourself, well I was so young when I first Started?
It Took A couple of Years Because I Didn't know who I was I was Still the Teenager?
But We always wrote our Own songs and we Always?
You know Had creative Control for One Because the label Didn't believe in Us so. They, were like I'll let Them do Whatever They want
And it Worked out in my advantage [Because], We proved Ourselves at a young age but I think
The biggest Thing Is
- I
Would Say Rehearse Practice and
you know it doesn't Matter if You're in front of
Target of Day Care [Whatever] [you] say it Takes
10,000 Hours and Hours Mad Master Exactly you, would agree With that Absolutely [and] [I'd] put the same amount of Effort Into
Whatever I did and so did the other Girls it Didn't Matter what it was and Eventually it Prepares you for Greatness
So Work Work Work Work Work [I] have always said ever Since I started working?
That I am my customer I
Want to Appeal to me what's Missing in my life?
What void Can I fill that will fill the Voids for
Everybody that's Like Me and my mother Would always Say Nobody's like you Martha forget it and I always Said Mother I
Am Like Everybody Else and you know [I] have chickens I have a garden I Scrub the Floors I vacuum my house
I'm just like everybody Else and
So she Finally got to understand what I was Talking About because I always want to Please me?
With what
We do do I want to buy it [do] I need it so it's the need in The one [Lot]
[of] People don't know Their Purpose and
If You don't know your Purpose
Your
Immediate Goal is to Figure that out
Because Otherwise You're Just wandering Around here so the moment you Can Figure out what it is you're Supposed to be Doing
The Sooner You are able to get about the Business of doing that I often get asked by
Younger Readers What I would Advise if You want to be a writer
This is the way I did it so that's the only Advice i Can give
You've Got to Read as much as you [Possibly] Can Because that's the best way to
Recognize Good Writing and to learn What Makes Bad Writing and Those are very [Good] things you'll Probably go
Through a Phase Where you imitate your Favorite writers That's Perfectly okay that's Another learning Process you
Resign Yourself to writing Lots and Lots of Rubbish
You Just got to write that out of your System and Sooner Or later You'll hit what you know you really?
Should Be doing and what is your genre and
Perseverance You've Got to persevere because it is A it's A
Career With A lot of Knock backs but the Rewards are Huge I don't mean
in the sense that if That's what you really want to do to be able to do it life long is the Best Thing in
[the] World
Very Rewarding but it's not a Career for People who are Easily Discouraged that's for Sure [and] to Their Parents
Don't Tell them it's Unrealistic
Never to Never Say That because even if They're not published writing
Well writing is the Passion of my life so it's an Important thing to do I
Think Most Forwards Like to play under Pressure or else you
Wouldn't Play The Forward Position but I do Like that Pressure and Sometimes you don't Always?
Succeed and That's okay and as A forward you have to
Find that Balance I mean you're Gonna [Shoot] five Times and Maybe you'll Score Once Maybe you
Won't you know Maybe you'll get Three goals out of Three Shots so?
It's a little Unpredictable and you just kind of got to go with it and Have Confidence in Yourself
Sometimes We don't Always Feel beautiful sometimes, We have our days Where you know We Feel under the Weather or sad Or?
Overwhelmed and I know for me Whenever I have those Days I try to
put on my Best Outfit my best Makeup and my
Sexy Heels and When you look good it Makes you feel good so i really know
[I'm] [a] strong [believer] when you're Feeling down you
Don't just Stay in The bed and Just you know Soaking that you Pull Yourself Together and it is the Beginning of
Overcoming Whatever You're going Through I'm working hard all day, [it'd] be Busy in The Kitchen Cooking and Making for my Videos
I need to leave this place Looking Clean and Fresh I'm Martha stewart so it has a bead [of] [S]
[Brick] on the Baking Soda
Bring on the Clean This Kitchen has to be Ready for the next big Scene The Fridge it's Filled With all my Favorite Food any
Funky Odors Can Really ruin my mood this Box here helps Food taste Fresher longer Stops Any Odors from Getting Stronger
My life is fueled by my being and being Fuels to doing so I come from a Centered
Place I come From the Focused Place I come from
Compassion
[It's] just my nature I come from a willingness to understand and to be Understood
and I come From wanting to to
To Connect I mean The secret of that Show for 25 Years Is that People Could See Themselves in me all?
Over The World They Could See Themselves in Me and even As i became
More and More
Financially Successful which, was A big Surprise to me I was like, oh Boy so exciting
[I] mean you got more Than that Thirty Thousand More Than Thirty Thousand by the time I was Thirty so?
so my
But what what I realized is Through the whole Process Because i'm Grounded in my Own?
Self
That Although I could have more Shoes
My feet Stayed on the ground Although I was wearing Better Shoes he's Kind of cute Today too?
[so] [i] could Keep my feet
On the Ground even Though i could get more Shoes and I could Understand I could Understand that it Really
Was because I was Grounded I've Done the was doing and Continue to this day to?
Do the consciousness Work I work at staying awake
Always Always Always Wanted to be a writer [and] Obviously
One of the a'right he want to dream of Supporting Yourself Through writing Definitely
It Better is A bit of Both Because
I was very much aware that Children's Books you do not
The Possibility of Supporting Yourself Solely by writing Children's Books is Slim that's that's the Reality of it which I was Fully
Aware of that so in in that sense this is all come as a Huge
Enormous Shock I'm Delighted Because I always wanted to write and Always have written but my Realistic side has not
Allowed Me to dream A part of what's happened to me Truthfully you know I wanted to?
Be an Olympic Gold medalist Since
That Since I was [7] Years Old so?
but that
Was a dream come True for Models or who?
My Role Model Is i mean I definitely looked up to kristine Lilly mia Hamm [abby] even in High School and Getting on the National
Team But I feel like i always wanted to kind of Make my parents Proud and They
Were like the two people [that] Came to every single Game [and] Just Where my biggest Fans so there are Many Struggles um in
Any Career This Career it's Tough Because
You Always Have to try to Figure out
What to do next and it's a lot of Pressure I do so Many [Different] things I'm Always being Pulled in so Many Different Directions
So the worst thing is trying to make Sure [I] keep
Myself Together Insane and I [know] [who] I am and um
Keep my life Balanced Still Make Time to
Spend With my family and my friends and Still Make Time for my Career
It's just trying to Figure out that Balance
Well i worked Really hard and I think that that working Hard and Have and
Making Money for your Hard Work that was Another Thing that I also Discovered as an Entrepreneur that
oh it's all well and good to Work Really hard but you must be
Compensated for your Hard Work and not be Greedy About it but be
Compensated Fairly and That when you look at the end of the Month that you actually have some Money in the Bank that you Could
Invest Or reinvest in your Business that you Have Actually Succeeded and Being A good Business Person as
Well and you Can Pay your your associates and your colleagues well
[You] Can Really Actually See that a Business is forming
That a Business is being Created that you are Actually being Productive
Dear Beautiful
[Brown-Skinned] Girl
And I use the word beautiful because I know that's Never A word you Would Call Yourself I?
Look Into your eyes and I See
The Light and Hope of Myself
in This Photo
You're Just About to Turn 20
Posing Outside The Television Station Where you, were Recently hired as a reporter
You Look Calm
You Look Happy
But I know How Scared you are
If I could Say Anything to you
It Would be
Relax
It's going to be okay girl
If you choose [to] use [your] Status and Influence to raise your Voice on Behalf of Those who have no [Voice] if you choose to
Identify Not Only With The Powerful but With the Powerless if You retain the Ability to Imagine Yourself
Into the Lives of Those who do not Have your advantages
then it will not only be your proud Families who Celebrate your Existence but Thousands and Millions of People
This Reality You [Have] Helped Change
We do not need Magic to transform our World
We carry all the Power We need inside Ourselves Already?
We have the power to Imagine Better?
You know it's not what I wanted them to See [I] just Wanted them to Feel the Passion and I wanted them to
To Grow That Passion Because This is Exactly what I dreamed of When I was a young Kid When I was [Watching] you?
This is what I dreamed of - I'm Gonna cry?
You're Gonna Make Me cry Stop
Just to dream Big Cuz Streams [Drop]
It was very Risky for me To Step out on my Own i'm Gonna leave A footprint on the?
Sands of Time
No There was being A?
Young woman [I] want to set the example that Is Possible for [Us] [to] own our Own Businesses and Own our Own Record Labels and
Sometimes We don't reach for the Stars Sometimes?
We are Satisfied with what People tell us we're Supposed to be Satisfied With and I'm Just [not] going Forth
We need here
I've done That everybody know who everybody knew all right I'll be I'm Saying I'm the President
[so] i just wanted to have A creative Meeting and
Figure out you know what the next Direction will be I
Booked The Studio Myself and Paid for the Studio Myself and I
Just Had fun I [just] did Whatever I wanted [to] do?
oh
my
Thank You Guys so much for [Watching] the Top 50 Rules theme is a new one for me and so if You Guys Have
Recommendations for what Theme you, want me to cover next leave it in the Comments Below and I'll see, what I can
Do I'd also love to know which of the women [that] we Featured?
Resonated With you the most leave it in the Comments and I [will] Join in the Discussion
Thank you so much for Watching [you] need to believe and I'll see you soon